at two hours and 15 minutes Bohemian
Rhapsody is certainly not a short movie
but there are still a stack of amazing
songs and scenes that were cut from the
final film yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
it's Jan here and in this video I'm
revealing and explaining seven cool
scenes and songs deleted from the new
Queen biopic keep watching to the end to
find out why the filmmakers cut some of
the epic live 8 finale and make sure you
subscribe and leave a comment about the
movie for a chance to win one of these
cool Bohemian Rhapsody merch packs while
early scenes in the movie show us how
freddie mercury first met and formed a
band with guitarist Brian May and
drummer Roger Taylor
there was another scene filmed that we
never got to see and that was how bass
guitarist John Deacon became part of the
group
Tim Staffel was Smiles original lead
singer and bassist and in the film he
quits the band the same night that
Freddie meets Brian and Roger there's a
line where Brian asks Freddie if he also
plays the bass which he doesn't
and then there was meant to be a
follow-up scene showing how the band
found their new bassist John Deacon
actor Joe mazzello who plays deacon says
they shot a proper introduction for his
character where he was approached by
Queen to join the band while I was at
work soldiering I can see why the scene
ended up getting scrapped in order to
keep the story moving forward but
mazzello says he wished the scene had
made it into the film as he feels it
shows what an accidental rockstar Deacon
was in real life Queen had several bass
guitarists before students of
electronics John Deacon met may and
Taylor at a social event in early 1971
and shortly after successfully
auditioned for the band throughout
Queens history deacon has been regarded
as the quieter more reserved bandmate
and he retired from the music business
in the late 1990s in the movie when
Queen first meet their new manager John
Reed he tells the band what he can do
for them including getting them on the
radio there may be the TV show Top of
the Pops and if that goes well a
promotional tour of Japan cut - the band
singing Killer Queen on Top of the Pops
followed by a montage of stage
performances which includes a little bit
of footage from the Japan tour Burtt Ben
Hardy who plays Roger Taylor has said
there's an additional deleted scene set
in Japan which features the band playing
the song thirty-nine and it was actually
one of Hardy's favorite days on set 39
which appears on Queens fourth album a
Night at the Opera tells the story of a
space traveler who
on a year-long journey but when he
returns discovers many more years of
actually passed and his loved ones have
died the song was written and sung on
the album by Brian May but in live
performances Freddy usually led the
vocals after the charismatic frontman
died however Brian is often sung that as
part of a tribute to Freddie and I
suspect in Bohemian Rhapsody the song
was meant to foreshadow in some way what
would happen when Freddie passed away I
imagined the song was eventually
discarded from the film though as there
was still so much to cover in Queens
story at this point by the way in
reality Queen had already toured Japan
and appeared on Top of the Pops before
John Reed became their manager in late
1975 though they did tour Japan again in
1976 this time under Reed's management
as part of their night at the opera tour
indeed as you might expect of a movie
much of Bohemian Rhapsody plays fast and
loose with Queens real-life story and I
talked more about that in my other video
which I'll link to at the end and in the
video description
a famous bit of Queen history that was
cut from the film was how Freddie
Mercury composed the catchy Elvis
Tribute song crazy little thing called
love in just 10 minutes on the guitar at
the same time as he was in the bar rami
malek did shoot that scene which sounds
like it would have been a fun little
moment in the movie but it ended up
getting the chop based on the movie's
soundtrack album it looks like the scene
was meant to appear between the tour
scene featuring the song now I'm here
and the scene where Freddy shows Mary
Austin video of the crowd singing love
of my life on the band's recent tour
Freddie Mercury's wild aside is alluded
to in Bohemian Rhapsody with several
scenes of his partying however the movie
keeps things strictly pg-13 according to
Alan leach who plays Paul prenta though
the snippets we see in the film of
Freddie visiting the Meatpacking
District in New York and specifically
the gay bar and sex club mineshaft were
originally part of a longer separate
scene which also continued outside the
club in the final film clips of the
mineshaft Zeena intercut with scenes of
the band in the studio recording another
one bites the dust the filmmakers
haven't said why they cut this specific
scene but Brian May and Roger Taylor
were producers on the film and they've
spoken previously about how they were
keen for the movie in general to really
emphasize Freddie's musical talent over
other aspects of his life which was so
often been the focus of tabloid gossip
Lucy Boynton who plays Mary Austin has
said that several of the scene she
shares with Malik's Freddie Mercury were
trimmed in the final film in order to
keep the story moving forward at a
decent pace also cut from the Mary and
Freddie scenes is how mercury came up
with Quinn's logo and more on why he
renamed the band from smile to Queen
there's a remnant of this moment in the
final film where Freddie and Mary talk
about the meaning of the new name queen
however what was chopped out is how
Freddie came up with the band's famous
emblem so we missed out on Freddie
explaining that Queens logo is made up
of the band members zodiac signs there's
two lions one for Roger Taylor and
another for John Deacon who are both
Leo's a crab for Brian May sign cancer
and two fairies for Freddie sign Virgo
Freddie placed those together with the
letter Q which contained a crown and
topped it all off with a Phoenix while
the need to keep up the pace of the
movie means that casual fans might not
realize the emblems origins hardcore
fans will doubtless have noticed the
brief glimpse we got of Freddie
sketchbook with various potential
designs he was working on two of the
movies highlights are when the band
records Bohemian Rhapsody together in
the studio and the film's climax when
they perform an incredible set at Live
Aid what we hear in the movie during
that big onstage sequence is Bohemian
Rhapsody Radio gaga and ayo crowd sing
along hammer to fall and we are the
champions now if you're a big Queen fan
you'll know that in real life the band
also performed another two songs at
Wembley that day crazy little thing
called love and we will rock you
and rami malek and his co-stars did
actually film the whole of that roughly
20 minute live aid set including those
two songs however as the film was
running long and we will rock you had
already appeared earlier it didn't make
the final cut I suspect crazy little
thing called love was cut from this part
of the film for the same reason however
because the filmmakers also ended up
cutting the scene where mercury composes
that song in the end crazy little thing
called love was missing from the movie
interestingly the Live Aid sequence was
the first thing they shot so Malick and
his fellow actors were really thrown in
at the deep end which makes it even more
amazing that they did such an
outstanding job bringing that massive
event to life and let's face it Malick
and Coe certainly had a lot to live up
to as Queen's performance that day has
frequently been labeled one of the
greatest live rock performances ever I
don't know about you but I'd have
you watch the cast perform crazy little
thing called love and we will rock you
again during the final sequence so
fingers crossed that we get to see the
full version of the live 8 gig on the
blu-ray now do you think any of these
deleted scenes or songs should have been
in the movie and what did you like best
about the film let me know what you
think in the comments below and remember
to subscribe for a chance to win one of
these cool Bohemian Rhapsody merch packs
tap left to learn about the biggest
changes Bohemian Rhapsody made to the
real story of Queen or tap writes for
another video you're sure to like let me
know if you enjoyed this and a thumbs up
her share is hugely appreciated thanks
for watching and see you next time you
PK movie lovers